[MUSIC PLAYING]
IDO GREEN: Hi.
I'm Ido Green, a developer
advocate for Actions on Google.
We wondered what would
be the most helpful to
developers creating apps
for their Google Assistant.
Would you want a T-shirt?
AUDIENCE: Ooh.
IDO GREEN: Maybe.
Access to Google engineers?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
IDO GREEN: Definitely. $200
monthly Google Cloud credit?
AUDIENCE: Yay.
IDO GREEN: Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: I want a T-shirt.
IDO GREEN: We've created a new
Developer Community Program
to support your
efforts in building
great apps for the
Google Assistant
and to celebrate
your accomplishments.
Making your first app
for the Google Assistant
available to users is definitely
something worth celebrating.
So we're going to give you $200
monthly Google Cloud credit.
AUDIENCE: How about a T-shirt?
IDO GREEN: OK.
We'll also give you a T-shirt.
AUDIENCE: Yay!
IDO GREEN: Make sure to wear
it when you meet our team
at events around the world.
Ready to get started but
don't know what to build yet?
We have a few good options.
You can discover great apps by
browsing the Google Assistant
directory.
You could also check our docs
and log to the Action console
to start building.
Or use one of our
existing templates
to finish your app in no
time and without any code.
Links to all those
resources and videos
about using Actions templates
can be found in the description
below.
Now, launching your first app
to users is half the battle.
We want to reward you
for all your hard work
and support those of you
who put in the extra effort
to build high-quality apps
that are getting traction
from users globally.
For every developer,
friends and family
are the first
users of their app.
To reach the next
milestone and gain traction
among global users,
you need to be
noticed by a community outside
your close group of friends--
or simply have incredibly
large social circle.
Getting users to try
your app is great.
Getting them to come back
again and again is even better.
If you build a
quality experience
that users can't
get enough of, we
want to contribute
to your efforts
to improve and grow your app.
As Actions on Google
continues to grow and roll out
to new countries, we'd
like the Google Assistant
users to enjoy great quality
apps in their native language.
If you make your app available
in two languages, one of which
should be a non-English variant,
and a minimum amount of users
engage with it in
both languages,
we'll help you on
your journey to build
a global community of users.
If at least one of your apps
reaches one of these three
milestones, we'll invite you
to join our community program
Google group.
There, we send an exclusive,
[? group-members-only ?] invite
to meet and talk
with Google experts--
either through Hangouts
or at the small VIP
events around the world.
We'll also ship
you a Google Home
to make it easier for you
to test and use your app.
You have a chance
to be on the ground
floor of a booming
community that's
working on the cutting edge of
the Google Assistant platform.
What more do you want?
AUDIENCE: Do you
have more T-shirts?
IDO GREEN: Visit the
YouTube description
below for more
information, including
links to our blog post about
the Developer Community Program.
Until next time, be wise
and create amazing apps
for the Google Assistant.
[MUSIC PLAYING]